[Música]
es una parte vital de la formación de
nuestros hijos somos estos cimientos que
dan seguridad fortaleza y a la vez los
impulsan para que sean
hombres independientes diariamente con
vivo y trabajo con niños y es a través
de sus experiencias y necesidades
propias de ellos que tengo la
posibilidad de tener una comunicación
directa con sus padres
y veo una generación de muchos padres
que están en la búsqueda de ser cada día
mejor de dar lo mejor a sus hijos sin
embargo hay faltas que llegan a cometer
que de una manera consciente o
inconsciente algunas de esas material
algunas de esas omisiones que llegan a
cometer son las comparaciones o bien no
permitir que nuestros hijos asuman
riesgos o vivan cambios inesperados
otras de las faltas que se pueden
cometer son los elogios excesivos
qué buscamos los padres cuando
comparamos a nuestros hijos no es porque
seamos malos padres muchas veces es
porque creemos que es la mejor manera
para motivarlos los éxitos que están
teniendo
con quienes los comparamos
veamos esta situación
sabiendo cómo lo pongo como antemano
sabiendo que tu hija es carencia de esa
habilidad psicomotora o de integración
en su lateralidad veamos es necesario
vamos a ver la presentación de baile de
nuestra hija
y al terminar su actuación la
felicitamos
pero hay un momento en que crecimos algo
tengo que hacer para que se esfuerce
para que sea mejor y el lanzar un
comentario como oye qué bien bailo tu
prima qué bárbara qué manera de moverse
en el escenario estuvo tan sincronizada
lo que dejamos de ver los padres están
comparados
al sentirse un niño comparado eso los
lastiman les duele porque ellos dejan de
ver su identidad propia dejan de ver que
ellos tienen un valor que lo distingue
otra de las faltas como ahorita
mencionaba son el no permitir que
nuestros hijos asuman riesgos
muchas veces los padres no permitimos
que nuestros hijos asuman riesgos
porque nos da mi libro y a veces es un
miedo real es un miedo a que les falte
algo en su seguridad tanto física o
emocional
sin embargo cuando permitimos que
nuestros hijos asuman riesgos eso los
hace sentirse seguros 10 y 2
los ayudará a crecer a informando su
carácter para que el día de mañana
tengan una personalidad
otra de las faltas los elogios excesivos
todos los padres buscamos desarrollar en
nuestros hijos una autoestima yo como
madre siempre lo busco nuestros hijos en
su momento lo he buscado
pero en el formar una buena autoestima
es permisible que
no se ha elogiado en cada momento
dependiendo de lo que haga estoy
hablando de unos elogios excesivos o
halagos excesivos porque cuando son los
halagos excesivos lo hacen sentirse tan
maravilloso tan único y es el más
poderoso necesaria que se siente
perfecto
entonces él dice si soy tan perfecto
para que el esfuerzo se coloca en la
zona de confort no nos motivamos a
superarse sin embargo cuando hay un
reconocimiento positivo los alentamos a
que se superen por ejemplo
el momento te toca ir a ver el partido
de fútbol de tu hijo y te das cuenta que
metió un gol hacia nosotros como padres
pues te sientes muy orgulloso muy
satisfecho y cuando llega lo recibes le
dices oye que con la somete este que va
al paro estuvo espectacular me he dado
cuenta que te has esforzado mucho me he
dado cuenta que ha sido tan constante y
tan responsable en tus entrenamientos si
es así
doblar a ser un buen delantero
es reconocer el esfuerzo es diferente a
los halagos cuando reconocemos el
esfuerzo él se va a enfocar en los
cambios que está el día de mañana el
decida cambiar y probar otras
habilidades y está muy bien pero él se
va a enfocar en las acciones en lo que
en el movimiento en ejecutarlo
bueno pues lo más lo que más desea un
hijo cuando nace lo que más desea un
hijo cuando las ve es sentirse amado
y esto es lo que quieres que lo vean que
lo acepten con todas estas habilidades y
potencialidades que tienen que lo
distinguen
con su talent
que se lo reconozcan porque el talento
es lo que lo va a forjar aire la
conquista de una creatividad
quiénes son
todos los hijos necesitan padres
presentes padres que estén pero para que
nosotros podamos ser un padre presente
primero hay que conocerlos nosotros
mismos tener un autoconocimiento donde
nos va a permitir tener un orden interno
donde vamos a poder reconocer nuestras
emociones nuestros sentimientos para
luego tomar acciones como padres
presentes conscientes y generadores de
una familia que tenga una atmósfera de
confianza esperanza en fe
cuando tu hijo cuando mi hijo
nacida en una familia
donde hay una confianza con una
atmósfera así
se va a atrever a participar en su
familia
dando sus opiniones sin el temor de
verse juzgado por sus padres o sus
hermanos pero él va a saber que están
sus padres sosteniéndolo dando de
seguridad impulsándolo
en la familia es donde se dan las
primeras experiencias de vida
nosotros como padres cómo vamos a
cultivar entonces es las necesidades del
pp les digo en la vida de una persona
hay dos grandes necesidades básicas las
emocionales y las espirituales
íntimamente relacionadas
nosotros como padres cómo podemos
cultivar fortalecer y continuar para
encontrar los necesarios los factores
necesarios para dar satisfacción a esas
necesidades emocionales
a través del abrazo a través de la
mirada
a través del tacto del juego
escucha
abrazar a nuestros hijos incluye algo
maravilloso ser algo maravilloso cuando
abrazamos es poner en contacto tu
corazón con el suyo
encontrar una sintonía es tan fuerte el
abrazo que en el momento en que se
abrazan entre los dos para una sintonía
en los corazones dos entonces se genera
en el cuerpo
una sintonía de paz
en estación de seguridad de fortaleza
es tan importante el abrazo que he
escuchado que es una gran terapia la
terapia extraordinaria
qué sucede en nuestro cuerpo
químicamente cuando abrazamos o cuando
somos abrazados hay una explosión de
hormonas una explosión de hormonas y
algunas de ellas es la oxitocina es una
hormona asociada con la generación en
nuestro cuerpo de dar una sensación de
paz de calma de sanación
de escuchar a nuestros hijos cuando
escuchamos a nuestros hijos entramos en
una empatía
y una escucha implica generosidad
generosidad porque porque voy a escuchar
las necesidades de mi hijo las mías las
voy a dejar aparte muchas veces lo que
buscan los hijos son solamente ser
escuchados y ser comprendido en lo que
ellos nos quieren decir
a veces cuando llegan de la escuela nos
nos cuentan cómo les ha ido
ellos nada más quieren que nos
escuchemos no queremos opiniones o
consejos solamente quieren que nos
escuchemos
mirar a nuestros hijos cuando miramos a
nuestros hijos con consciencia
los padres y el hijo
una unión
última pregunta
al mirarlos ellos nos permiten entrar en
su mundo
cuando miremos a nuestros hijos hay que
cuidar entrar en su campo visual porque
ahí es donde lo siente presente ahí es
donde ellos van a ver que nosotros somos
testigos
otra cosa maravillosa la oportunidad del
juego cuando nosotros como padres
jugamos con nuestros hijos de una manera
integrada de una manera de una manera
realmente precedente
tenemos una gran oportunidad allí en el
juego de enseñar los valores
porque porque allí es donde enseñamos a
respetar el turno de los demás acceder a
ser tolerantes en el tiempo y forma de
los llamados a controlar esa frustración
que se siente cuando uno pierde
como son más libres y ahí es donde
pedimos que caminemos con nuestros hijos
que ellos se sientan acompañados
respetados
apurados
teniendo un contacto físico y a la vez
un espacio
porque un contacto
sin espacio es asfixiante
pero un espacio sin contacto creado
el mejor regalo que le podemos dar a
nuestros hijos
es nuestro propio ser muchas gracias
[Aplausos]